Nabi-Alexandre Chartier
nous fait visiter les lieux.
- La cuisine...
- Danielle Lysaught
et Paul Hamelin ont trouvé
une façon originale de soutenir
les artistes émergents.
Le couple a décidé de convertir
une partuperbe demeure
de style Renaissance française,
en centre d'artistes
nouveau genre.
PAUL HAMELIN, copropriétaire,
Projet Casa
- Quand on a acheté la maison,
ici, Danielle avait l'idée d'en
faire notre lieu de résidence.
avait aussi... l'idée
est venue assez rapidement que
c'était un espace qu'on voulait
qui soit disponible aussi pour
les gens de Montréal.
DANIELLE LYSAUGHT,
copropriétaire, Projet Casa
- Oui, oui, c'était trop grand
pour nous, là. Les enfants sont
partis, on n'a pas l'idée de
tenir des grandes réceptions.
Donc... puis c'est
un bel espace.
- Passionnés d'art
et de culture, c'e
l'informatique qu'ils ont fait
fortune. Après avoir créé
des bourses scientifiques,
investi dans le domaine
communautaire et financé l'ainat
d'oeuvres pour des musées,
le couple souhaitait étendre
son action philanthropique
différemment.
- On a due le milieu
était... était vraiment
intéressant, le milieu
des galeries, le milieu
des conservateurs, le milieu
stes. Et puis,
ce qu'on aimait beaucoup,
c'est la possibilité d'être
en contact avec ces gens-là.
- Une de nos pièces préférées...
- Ces gens-là, ce sont
des artistes comme Jannick
Deslauriers, qui termine
actuellement sa maîtrise à
la prestigieuse Université Y
et qui réside et travaille
à la Casa quand elle revient
à Montréal.
JANNICK DESLAURIERS,
artiste visuelle
- Je trouve que le support
de Danielle et Paul, puis il y a
d'autres personnes qui le font
de manière différente, mais
ça permetanéité.
C'est comme : ah, je veux faire
ce projet-là, je veux m'inscrire
en maîtrise... Il n'y a pas
de programme pour ça là.
- Depuisture
en juillet 2020, Projet Casa,
qui est situé sur la rue
de l'Esplanade à Montréal,
face au mont Royal, a accueilli
itions mettant
en vedette 50 artistes
et qui ont été vues par près de
3500 visiteurs. Un projet
entièrement privé, réalisésansÉ.
- Moi dans le milieu
des technologies, j'ai beaucoup
travaillé toute ma vie avec
des jeunes. Là, c'est dans
un autre milieu, mais je vois,
la même... la même passion,
le même enthousiasme,
la même détermination.
- Puis c'est des personnes
qui s'interrogent beaucoup,
qui réfléchissent, qui sont
vraiment engagés dans tout...
différents aspects de
la société. Donc, ça fait
vraiment des rencontres
enrichissantes.
- La prochaine exposition
à Projet Casa débute
le 20 janvier, ça s'appelle
"En constante transformation".
C'est l'e découvrir
les installations, performances
et vidéos de neuf artistes
en début de carrière,
d'échanger avec eux et de
r ce lieu d'exception.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.